لطالما ارتبطت بعض الحركات كالنظر الى
الاعصار او فرك الانف بطريقه معينه بالشخص
الكذب لكن الخبراء لهم راي اخر فالشخص
الذي ينظر الى اليسار او يفرق انفه يمكن
ان يكون بالفعل متلاعبا او مخادعا لكن فقط
اذا كانت هذه الايماءات غير اعتياديه
بالنسبه له فبحسب تقرير نشر في موقع فان
التفسير لتلك الكلمات والاشارات ينطبق اذا
كانت غير محتاجه بنسبه لذلك الشخص الدراسه
تقول لنا استخدام لغه الجسد لتحديد
المخادعين يستغرق وقتها وادي دراسه ومعرفه
جيده للشخص نفسه لذا من السهل دائما
اكتشاف التلاعب عندما ياتي من شخص تعرفه
جيدا وعلى دراجه جيدا بلغته جسده وعند
ملاحظه تغييرها يسهل كشف الكذب الى على
كلن والمزيد عن العلامات الخداع
علامات حددها العلم يمكن من خلالها كشف ما
اذا كان الشخص كاذبا او محتالا منها ان
نقروا على القدم غالبا ما تكون علامه على
الانزعاج او نفاذ الصبر وقد يؤدي النقر
على القدمين ايضا الى تسريع قرارك ما قد
يخدم مصلحته المتلاعب وايضا حقه الذقن
لمحاوله اظهار عدم اليقين غالبا ما يستخدم
لاجبار الاخرين على الاستسلام على سبيل
المثال ان يظهر لك انه لن يستطيع القيام
بامر ما ليخدعك كي تقوم انت بالمهامه
نيابه عنه فركوا اليدين والرقبه من الممكن
ان تدل على التوتر او الشعور بالدم عند
استغلال شخص اخر كذلك وميض العين وحركاتها
فالمحتال يمكن ان ينظر في العين لتحديد ما
اذا كانت الضحيه تنطلي عليها الخدعه او
الكذب كذلك تغير اوضاع الجسم فاذا شعرت ان
شخصا ما حاولوا السيطره عليك فابدا في
الانتباه الى عدد مرات تغير وضع الجسم
يمكن ان يكون قد تم استدراجك الى حالتي
رضوخ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي الاستوديو ينورنا المدرب العالمي
لتطوير القاده الاعلاميين عمار شهاب اهلا
بك سيد عمار
ههه بلا ما انت بالعيد على الهواء طيب طيب
انت كخبير في الموضوع واضطر اتدرب ناس هل
هناك بالفعل همم اشارات ايماءات معينه في
الشخص اذا شفتها تكشف انه مخادع جدا طبعا
بلغه الجسد لما احنا بندرب سواء حدا مهم
او حتى الناس العاديين في ثلاث اشياء
اساسيه اللي هي باللغه الانجليزيه تعبير
تعبير العين الدقيقه وتعبير الوجه الدقيقه
وتعبير الجسد الدقيقه المايكروفون
وهي تفاصيل كثير دقيقه تعكس الحاله لا
واعيه للشخص امامك اهو وبالذات انه هو عم
يحكي من النيرفز السيستم تبعه فلما هو مخ
بيطرب او بيصير اي في افكار سواء كذب او
مش صدق او في مش ضروري كذب ممكن عم يتهرم
الاجابه او بده يعمل شيء معين فبتلاقي كل
هذه الاشياء تظهر على تعبيره وهو بيصير
فيه تفاصيل بنسميها التسريبات لغه الجسد
طيب عمار هناك
حق الذقن تحريك الرجل واحد يخدع ويكذب هل
لديك انت اشارات ماء طبعا همم العقل
البشري همم هون في بهيفر كثير مهم العقل
البشري العقل اليمين مسؤول عن الابداع
والعقل اليسار هل يفيد مشاهديكي بهذه
المعلومات المهمه جدا بس
زوجاتنا كثير يستعملوها والازواج
فالعقل اليمين مسؤول عن الابداع والعقل
اليسار المسؤول عن التركيز فلما بينظر
الشخص وهو بيكلمك
فبالتالي عم يعمل ابداع الكلب بنعمل
عقله اليسار فبالتالي هو عم بيركز
بالاستجلاب ذاكره معينه للاستجلاب همم اي
شيء من راسه او من تجاربه
بتعرف انه هو عم يصدق اكثر انه هو عم
يستحذر شيء موجود بقرشيف عقله وهكذا فهي
هي هي المعادله البسيطه وهي لغه ننطق
بالنهايه لغه الجزائر
الكواليس عمار تقول لي انه اهم القاده في
العالم يتدربوا عندهم ماستر على لغه الجسد
مش ماستر يعني وحده البروتين
اصلا في شيفره بين القاده يعني احنا ما
بنستدعونا نحلل الشخصيه او خطاب او ظهور
معين لرئيس ليش تلاقي العالم كلها بتنشغل
فيه لانه فيه شيفره يعني مثل ما في لغه
اسمها الاختصار والاختزال مثلا بالكاجبه
او بي سي اي اي او بي اي كمان في لغه
شيفره بلغه الجسد او في مدرستين على 200
بصراحه بالقانون الماضي في المدرسه
الامريكيه ولا المدرسه الروسيه وحمله
البروتين اصلا فهو محقق 1,000 مره بحياته
وممارسه كل هذه الاشياء مره وصار باللف
اللي هو بيعمل لغه جسد مقصوده ما في ولا
حركه بيعملها حتى هو بيسربنا احيانا فلان
ولا فلان ولا فلان بيشربوا لبعض الجسد
نقرا فيها ما لا يقال اللهم بين السطور او
سر الظهور نفسه يعني واحده مثل الملكه زي
ما شفتي حدا بيحلل مثلا الواحد بتمنى لك
طبعا لا لانه هي اوردي ذا ماستر باللغه
الجسد يعني هي اوردي همم مطور الجهاز كامل
وهو اللي بيجيب استعمالاتها بالمحققين او
قاده او اعلاميين مثل حضاراتكم فكل هذه
الاشياء اللي احنا بندربها بطريقه حديثه
جدا طيب انت خبير هذا الموضوع يا عمار
يقولوا عدم المعرفه
راح انت يعني بعض الاشارات تكون من طبيعه
الشخص والبعض الاشارات تعكس فعلا انه
مخادم او مخادع وغير صادق الى اي مدى هذا
الموضوع يتعبك انت شخصيا يعني كاشفهم كلهم
وقاده انه انت كيف عايش
عائلتها وكده شوف الانسان
فانت بتشوف نفسك او عائلتك او ابنك او
زوجتك ما بتكون انت يا عم خلاص
دائره اللي هي الملاحظه والتدقيق يعني
لازم يتصرفوا اللي بيكشفه يعني هو المفروض
يكون في لغه مقصوده يعني الشخص المدرب
بطريقه صحيحه اهم شيء اذا الموجه نصائح
للناس بهذا الموضوع لا يعمل له الجسد اول
شيء المعرفه المعرفه بلغ الجسد طبعا في
اسرار يعني نحن هذا الشيء ضربه اليوم ب
222 ب 2000 و2005 كم ممنوع ضربه لانه هو
غذاء ملكي لشخصيات اوقات العالم او اصحاب
السلطه وحتى وبعدين نقلنا للاعلاميين
وعملنا نهضه بالاعلام بهذا الموضوع همم
فهي مش شغله لاي حدا مش شغله عامه بس مع
الوقت اليوم احنا بنطلع علومه اسرار كانت
قبل هيك السريه بس اليوم صار في اسرار
اخرى همم
حصه اضيفك بنحكي عنها وتكشفها شكرا جزيلا
المدرب العالمي عمر شهاب نورتنا يا عمار
انت